I believe that it's very important that
information that you get from
direct-to-consumer genetic tests should
not be considered in isolation it has to
be considered in conjunction with other
information relating to your age your
lifestyle your diet in exactly the same
way that when you go to your GP and
they're trying to diagnose you they
don't just try and measure one thing
they consider that in conjunction with
lots of other information so that they
can make the right choice over the
appropriate treatment regime and so in
exactly the same way you have to
interpret information from
direct-to-consumer genetic testing in
conjunction with all of the other
information about yourself and then that
will help you make informed decisions
about whether this information really
can provide some useful insights that
might alter your lifestyle